so I was sitting with my friends on the
stairs of a fountain at the center of my
favorite square and Rome where I used to
gather with my friends to have a few
laughs and drinks when all of a sudden I
heard this loud burp behind me and I
turned and I asked who's that and that's
one loud burp and actually the person
who had done that was a girl an American
girl who herself asked me are you
American and I told her that it was a
time and that was really surprising and
we started chatting and I actually got
to know one of my best friend's were
sitting next to her that is Garrett and
this is one of the surprising and
unexpected ways in which languages can
actually change in revolutionize your
life imagine a prison when light hits
that prison you will see its basic
components you are that light and
languages are like that prison which
help you show and broaden literally the
fastest of your personality think about
it for a second when you speak a foreign
language your facial features the
thoughts that you think your actions
your reactions are all slightly
different than when you speak your
mother tongue and we only have one life
it's true but it's also true that the
more languages you speak the more lives
we can live with in one live span
learning a language is a little bit like
running a marathon you learn a lot of
valuable life lessons by doing that for
example you learn the importance of
being humble the importance of knowing
yourself knowing when to speed up and
when to slow down the importance of
trial in their daily routine
irregularity habits belief in yourself
and I have learned these life lessons
through language and have carried them
over into other fields and domains of
life for example I have learned how to
become more productive how to develop
good sleeping and eating habits so it
has brought about a change in my life
overall
[Music]
traveling is in and of itself an amazing
experience it doesn't matter where you
go and it doesn't matter how many
languages you speak but if you speak the
local language or you speak many
languages it changes it completely
changes your experience back in the days
when I used to live in Paris I used to
carry out this social experiment I used
to walk into bars speaking English and
asking things around and the reaction
was obviously very cold but then and
within the same day I used to go to
other bars and speak in French and the
reaction was completely different which
goes to show that human beings all
across the globe have the same desires
the same actions the same thoughts the
same reactions and only apparently we
are different through the barrier of
language every language that you learn
is like a key that unlocks a new pathway
to human experience when you go to the
gym and you see all these big guys you
realize that the reason why their
muscles are so big is because they work
out differently from the muscles
actually we cannot see the brain itself
but the brain works in exactly the same
way if you make your brain work your
brain will become smoother leaner and
more efficient and through language
learning that can happen very fast
language learning has amazing benefits
in terms of other learning other
languages for example when I started
learning Dutch after learning German or
learning Portuguese after learning
Spanish I was astounded at the rate at
which I was acquiring these languages
which is natural because these languages
were similar to the languages I already
knew but in general the more languages
you learn the more cognitive benefits
you're reap for example I am more
socially and culturally aware I am a
better imitator I'm a better listener I
think I'm a more empathic person and a
more caring person imagine casting a net
into the ocean the bigger and the better
the net the more fish you're gonna get
now think about all these social events
you have participated in when you speak
another language and you meet a person
who speaks that language even a few
words and that language can make a
difference because you're establishing a
direct natural and emphatic relationship
with that person
and that makes all the difference when
it comes to establishing connections
making long-lasting relationships
friendships and even love which takes us
to the next point so this this is what
happened 2017 a prog I was sitting with
my friends at a hostel and then we
started talking to these three French
girls were surprised that I spoke French
and I spoken well and then thanks to
that I actually established a connection
I got to know her better and eventually
she would become my girlfriend now the
interesting thing is that speaking
French not only helped me connect make
this connection but it hope also helped
me solidify and cement this relationship
because the quality of the relationship
the empathy between the two of us that
was different and imagine like speaking
languages like having a little Cupid
shooting the arrow between you and
another person
it actually makes love a thrive and I've
learned that you know the important
message that love is the same Universal
message for everyone but it's wrapped up
and coated in different cultures and
different cultural codes and to unlock
that you need to speak foreign languages
back in the days in 2010 when I moved to
Paris I didn't know exactly what to do
but I knew that I had a big passion for
languages and eventually a language was
cut up with me and found me and I
started working with languages so I told
myself bingo I do what I love and I love
what I do but you don't have to
necessarily work with languages meaning
you have to be a translator or you have
to be an interpreter you can be whatever
you want but if you speak languages if
you have a good command of languages
that can actually make your career in
improve and you can find jobs much more
easily because with languages you not
only acquire words and sentences but you
also acquire a command of the cultural
structures and cultural codes underlying
negotiations or other things that can
actually make your life and the life of
the company or the organization your is
much easier and smoother imagine
speaking languages like having it
box the more languages you speak the
more tools you have to do whatever you
want the bottom line of all this is that
learning a language or many languages is
never ever a waste of time it's not just
a matter of learning new sounds or new
sentences or new words
it's about being a more being a more
competent person and more socially and
culturally aware person in the end it's
about being more empathic more
understanding and more humane and we
need this in this globalized world so if
you're thinking of learning a language
just do it now because it will have a
huge impact not only on your life but on
the life of those who surround you if
you want to know more just click on the
link in the description box below the
video and you will be able to read an
article that I put together about this
topic on my brand new website Luke Allen
perello calm
[Music]
you